[Music]
there are plenty of horror stories that
begin
innocuously enough a new home a camping
trip with friends
a doll purchased at an estate sale
this one starts with some ponds
the same set of ponds that james our
master of microscopes has been sampling
every week for the past three years
which means that he's collected so many
microbes from these waters that you
might think they'd get
a bit boring or redundant but
you should never underestimate nature's
capacity
for surprise
recently james came home with some
samples from these ponds and as usual
he prepared some slides and checked on
the organisms within
finding some nematodes like this one
slithering about on the slide
and all seemed well so he stored the
slides
and his new friends in a humidity
chamber and waited to observe them
after a few more days but two days later
all would not be well
this is where we build our suspense in a
movie
this would be the moment where we assess
the unsettling basement or the dark
woods
and then consider retreating to safety
this
is the creepy doll only there hasn't
been any thumps in the middle of the
night
so everything seems okay right
we're looking at the spores of a fungus
one belonging to the group arthrobotras
and when it's just floating around like
this seems quite harmless
especially when compared to the
nematodes we showed earlier which are
part of a whole family of worms that are
notorious for their parasitic lifestyle
and if you were to write off
arthrobotras as a potential threat
you would be correct most of the time
it does spend much of its life aligned
with the dead
but only to sustain itself on the
remains of decayed life and organic
matter
arthrobotra species are found all around
the world
occupying everything from soil to animal
feces
and the many varied climates that make
up our
planet and wherever it is the fungus
ensures that nutrients like nitrogen
from dead organisms
and other waste cycle through ecosystems
but when nitrogen is scarce these fungi
will resort
to hunting it down from living sources
and what better prey than the nematode
a fellow dweller of the soil and one of
the most
abundant animals on earth
when james put his slides into the
humidity chamber
he had no notion of what these nematodes
would be facing and so
no expectation of what he would find
but when the slides came back out what
he observed was something
he'd only seen once before in a drawing
done two years ago
by one of his close friends caitlyn
solback
in it you can see a nematode whose body
has been clinched into segments by some
kind of
bulbous thing what you're seeing
is the fungus's most brutal design
but to get there it must morph from
decomposer
to predator no longer consuming what has
already
been dead but actively killing
it begins by weaving a trap out of
itself it threads the hyphy of its
mycelium
out and then back in forming a living
loop
that repeats to form a net
but a net is only one part of a trap the
other part
is the lure the fungi can find nematodes
by following traces of their
pheromones like their breadcrumbs and
more nefariously
they can mimic the smell of certain food
cues
to draw the worm in like a siren working
through scent
instead of song the nematode has no
reason to suspect anything
even as it swims closer and closer and
eventually through the fungal rings but
as it does
the movement of worm and water triggers
the rings
to constrict the worm is trapped
but the worst is still yet to come
the fungus is hyphy begin to grow
off from the loop puncturing the worm's
cuticle
and paralyzing it the threads swell
up into a bulb that produces more hyphae
to spread through the rest of the
nematode and then
the fungus feeds and feeds
quickly digesting the rest of the
nematode's body
from within it is a gruesome death
[Music]
here is one nematode just recently
trapped
and here is the worm again four days
later
you can see the infection bulb where the
fungus first
punctured and expanded and the whole
body of the worm
seems taken over no longer a clear tube
but instead a corpse that has become
home
to its cause of death
the arthrobotras fungi are not the only
ones capable of trapping and feeding
upon nematodes there is a whole range
of nematode trapping fungi with their
own methods though the species
arthrobatrus oligospora
is perhaps the most plentiful of these
fungi and also
the best studied maybe it's just us
but it's somewhat unsettling to realize
that this
insidiousness is all the work of a
fungus
a thing that can seem so inert compared
to the
wiggling active worm that it targets
but fungi do have a kinship with horror
stories
their frequent role as decomposers
naturally connects them
with the dead plus they come equipped
with their own creeping sense of dread
with
images of mycelia weaving through bodies
and authors have drawn inspiration from
the notion of
fungal horror there are many works like
the famous gothic tale
we have always lived in the castle or
the short story
the voice in the night or recent novels
like mexican gothic and wanderers
that draw on everything from poisonous
mushrooms
to colonizing fungi to create their
terror
but whatever we seek to scare ourselves
with in fiction
horror has its purpose in nature
as we've pointed out nematodes are one
of the most abundant animals
on earth they play an important role in
decomposition
but they're also the source of many
diseases both in
animal bodies and in plants so having
them be
slightly less abundant is important to
our ecosystem as well
in fact scientists have been studying
these fungi
to develop better nematode fighting
strategies for agriculture
so as is the case with many good horror
villains
there's a version of this story where
the nematode trapping fungus
is the hero unless of course
you're the nematode
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and of course thank you to all of the
people on this screen right now
if you like this show these are the
folks you should be thanking
they are our patrons on patreon and you
can become one of them
by going to patreon.com journey2micro
thank you so much to everyone who's been
able to do that
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby